Brighton is a remained town seven in ten
here voted to stay in Europe which makes
life a bit awkward if you're a lever
it's really really tough people are very
very intolerant of the brexit fear here
unfortunately
so when cartoonist Michael Lightfoot
came out in support of brexit it didn't
go down very well with his remain
friends I've lost so many friends over
it I've you know it's been terrible you
know when you've lost them because they
disconnect from with you on Facebook and
that sort of thing or um yeah there it
is because of your view on brexit yes
just because just because of that
hopefully Brooks it's going to be a
success but by which I mean hopefully is
going to make things better in the
country overall I'm certainly not going
to be swinging from the rafters with joy
on January the 1st what's it like being
a brexit campaigner in a remain it's
pretty lonely and it's very difficult
non-stop sort of arguing with people and
writing leaflets having to get them
printed the whole thing's been like a
vast psychological war on a national
scale is it possible for both sides to
live and let live I think it can be and
I hope it can be it'd be a sad thing if
we couldn't what will you be doing to
mark brexit day there's this thing about
Big Ben will it bond will it not bond so
we've all bought bills and I've bought
my listen birdies
you see and so as as as everyone
important those it's not about the size
of your bong that matters
nowhere else in Britain wanted brexit
more than Boston 75 percent of voters
here voted to leave the EU the brexit
capital of Britain some have called it
Boston has the highest proportion of
Eastern European workers than anywhere
else in the UK in over the last few
years that has been a source of friction
at times it's led to Boston being
labelled Britain's most divided town and
what's interesting is after brexit can
this town begin to heal itself
my name's Andy Azad and I'm a resident
in Boston and he says immigration isn't
a bad thing if the town gets extra money
for things like doctors dentists in
schools if we don't get help and support
from central government then we're still
about these issues in five years time
has brexit the brexit thing has it had
an impact on on your life I'm interested
I think so I think on everybody I mean
let's face it even divided families hmm
there was many of my family that voted
remained there was many of my family
devoted leave and when you get to me at
Christmas time you're still discussing
brick city's pros and cons
do you think ultimately Boston will get
the brexit that it voted for that's a
that's a difficult one I mean if you're
going to ask my personal opinion I think
a lot of people are going to be
disappointed my name is Lee Alexa I'm
came from Latvia Violette has been in
the UK for 10 years she lives in Boston
with her two children
what's life like in the UK life is like
better you get more paid I feel
comfortable and relaxing more what do
you hope
life will be like after brexit for you
and your children here in the UK I think
coming maybe a little bit harder be more
expensive so I don't know what's
happening will be after breaks it by the
end of the day Britain will officially
be out of the EU those who've weathered
the storm hoped for fairer days ahead
Nick Martin Sky News